[Musica]
buonasera a tutti sembra strano che una
persona che ha cavalcato pedale finale
olimpiche che ha lavorato fatto qualche
esperienza in televisione possa essere
emozionata ma lo sono veramente
tantissimo
qual è secondo voi la parola che più
spesso viene abbinata agli atleti che
hanno ottenuto risultati che hanno vinto
medaglie ai campionati del mondo alle
orecchie e talento il talento è una
parola che affascina tantissimo che
colpisce che fa che fa notizia molto
spesso fregiavano titoli in cui c'è
scritto il talentuoso nuotatore
intervista dall'innato talento pur ecco
è arrivato il calciatore che mancava
quello con una di talento che risponderà
il mondo ebbene sì è appunto una parola
che che viene tritata e chissà quante
persone nella nostra strada abbiamo
incontrato che hanno che aveva con
talento quanto i compagni di classe dal
talento cristallino per lo studio o
quante persone con un talento pazzesco
per l'arte ne abbiamo conosciuti
tantissimi e sembrava che quel paletto
segnasse in qualche modo il loro il loro
futuro è una parola molto affascinante
che sicuramente tantissimi sportivi di
alto livello sono persone che hanno
avuto talento l'anno anche molto
allenato ma in realtà e la tenacia la
caratteristica che veramente più
identifica la carriera e la vita di uno
sportivo di una persona di successo
nessuna persona che io abbia mai
contratto diciamo nelle mie cavalcate
nelle mie esperienze sportive
sul podio è una persona che non ha avuto
con tenacia piuttosto magari non aveva
un grande talento ma con la tenacia ha
potuto sopperire
io penso della mia vita di essere essere
stata una persona tenace sono state
appena 5 ne sono accorta un po in
ritardo forse me ne sono resa conto con
il tempo mi sono resa conto di essere
stata tenace sin da bambina era un'arte
caccia sicuramente spuntata grazie
motivazioni dal
totale dalla passione il mio sport mi
dava ho sempre avuto un grande amore per
quello quello che facevo e quindi forse
in qualche modo mi mi rimaneva naturale
riuscire ad essere tenace parlavo della
mia esperienza da bambina perché in
realtà quando vuoi fare sport ma
ovviamente devi anche continuare a fare
quello che il tuo dovere di studiare
alla scuola tutti i giorni amari compiti
e possibilmente essere però una
strategia dell'anno e per me era stato
quasi subito un po un po complesso
perché io che è allenato in un'altra
città io sono di trieste andavo tutti i
giorni a udine e li accompagnava una
persona molto tenaci mia mamma il primo
vecchio tenaci mi accompagnava era più o
meno un'ora abbondante direi di macchina
e quello rai ho approfittato per fare i
compiti molto spesso non riuscivo a
finirli prima di iniziare prima di
iniziare l'allenamento
però ovviamente non ci andavo a scuola
senza averli finiti per cui il domani
visto che la sera tornavo
dell'allenamento veramente finita
l'indomani mi svegliavo all'alba e via
mira a completare quello che che mi
mancava devo dire che le difficoltà sono
state tante anche perché molto spesso a
scuola senza sin da bambina si terrebbe
meritare avevo trovato insegnanti e
pensavano che lo sport fosse soltanto
una perdita una perdita di tempo e che
questo spesso foto mi doveva dare un
voto guardava la prima sul registro
quante assenze avessi fatto piuttosto
che giudicare il reale profitto però la
tenacia non mi ha mai fatto mollare sono
riuscita a concludere gli studi
scolastici con con un buon successo e
alla fine sono anche stata premiata
perché diciamo che alla maturità ho
ricevuto i complimenti proprio per
essere riuscita ad abbinare una buona
carriera scolastica dei risultati
sportivi che ancora quell epoca moderna
eccellenti ero ancora una ragazzina il
bello doveva doveva ancora venire
poi sono stata al tenace sicuramente
nell'affrontare delle ulteriori
difficoltà ma del resto non esiste
tenacia se non ci sono difficoltà perché
chi è tenace lo è perché ha superato
degli ostacoli perché ha fatto magari un
po più fatica degli altri e la mia
carriera diciamo tra le grandi
nel dritti insomma la squadra alla
squadra dei sogni
io ho avuto la fortuna di far parte di
una squadra che è fortissima da ormai 30
anni il dream team del fioretto
femminile l'avevo degli idoli
incredibili delle donne che sono state
di grandissima ispirazione per me è
all'esordio esordio mondiale con la
squadra nazionale ero in ritiro
collegiale e la settimana prima
stiamo tirando dagli lo stavo
allenandomi veramente bellissimo sentivo
che qualcosa sta veramente cambiando
nella mia della mia carriera sportiva
stavo per fare il salto di qualità
bene la settimana prima del di quel
mondiale di quel sogno finalmente
raggiunto mi si rompe in si rompe il
ginocchio mi si rompe in maniera
violenta hanno sentito un forte un forte
dolore avevo capito che a quel mondiale
non ci starei andata e lì per lì
ovviamente è che molto è montato su una
grande una grande disperazione ma in
realtà subito la grande la grande
energia e valutare venuta fuori la
voglia di riprendermi con tenacia a
quello che era stato portato via dai
caso soprattutto mi ricordo una frase
che per una stanza di grande ispirazione
ogni giorno quando da una riabilitazione
ne ho fatti otto mesi per ritornare per
ritornare in pedana
vi ricordo che chiesero indietro la tuta
della nazionale club orton al ministro
romano i magazzinieri mi disse a marghe
rivede spiace però se devi restituire ma
perché non ce l'avevo con sé più per la
riserva per me era stato ovviamente un
colpo al cuore mi ricordo il dolore su
merola era una ragazzina avevo vent'anni
per cui per me aver conquistato quella
quella maglia è stata una cosa
meravigliosa
poter condividere un'esperienza così
importante con le mie compagne figurate
di aver espugnato il campo da bambini
però quella quel momento mi ha fatta
sicuramente quella frase quelle parole
mi hanno per quanto in delicate
ovviamente mi hanno fatta affrontare
ogni giorno con grande tenacia la
riabilitazione e penso che in realtà
scusatemi
[Musica]
quello è stato è stato il mio primo
infortunio purtroppo è il primo di una
lunga serie
ho avuto tanti infortuni avuto otto
interventi chirurgici dallo stesso
ginocchio è però sempre cercato di
rialzarmi
alle volte ce l'ho fatta e sono stata
felice perché dopo periodi veramente
lunghi e difficoltosi e dolorose sono
riuscita a tornare in pedana sono
riuscita a fare dei risultati che mi
hanno ripagato sicuramente di tutti e
tutti i sacrifici
altre volte invece non ce l'ho fatta
non ce l'ho fatta a ritornare ai livelli
cui era abituata cui cui aspiravo però
mi ricordo proprio l'ultimo nell'ultimo
mio infortunio
perché io su una pedana ho finito la mia
carriera per terra
l'ottava volta è stata una rottura
importante dopo tanti interventi quella
è stata la rottura definitiva
sono caduta su questa pedana ed a quella
pedana non mi ci sono più realizzata
però questo ovviamente quello che
sembrava in realtà un dramma all'inizio
perché poi dovete sapere che è proprio
quello il momento più difficile per uno
sportivo lasciare lasciare la carriera e
ovviamente così un momento un momento di
difficoltà qualcosa su cui dobbiamo
lavorare moltissimo dobbiamo anche farci
farci aiutare da un argomento di grande
discussione anche anche adesso con un
problema che affronta che adesso con i
miei colleghi della commissione
nazionale atleti ai cori davvero un
periodo molto molto difficile per una
società fondamentalmente poi quando non
puoi scegliere come finire la sua
carriera
ovviamente risulta tutto più complesso
però io sono sempre stata è abituato a
pensare positivo sicuramente il mio
sport mi ha dato degli elementi per
poterlo fare degli strumenti che
utilizzo tutt'oggi nella mia nella mia
vita nella vita di tutti i giorni nella
quotidianità prima pensavo che la
tenacia fosse quasi una virtù a fondo
perduto no quando era la riabilitazione
e sentivo che ce la stanno mettendo
tutta sentivo che che avevo voglia di
ritornare che hanno voglia di rientrare
in pedana però non sapevo quale poteva
essere l'epilogo non lo sapevo
a che livello sarei tornata non sapevo
quando pone
sono tanti punti di domanda però io ci
credevo e avevo delle delle forti
motivazioni
una volta finita la carriera sportiva ho
avuto una grande fortuna e ho capito che
la mia vita no non è vero gr finita su
quella su quella pedana ma avevo ancora
tante cose da fare c'è stato un evento
bellissimo che mi ha fatto ringraziare
in realtà di aver subito quel quell
ultimo infortunio perché qualche mese
dopo aver appeso il segreto ai chiodo è
arrivata la sorpresa più bella è nata
mia figlia eleonora mi sono resa conto
quanto quegli strumenti che lo sport mia
mi ha dato mi abbia insegnato e tutte
quelle cose che ho imparato negli anni
della mia carriera agonistica
tutte cose che io credevo nomi sarebbero
servite perché per me l'obiettivo era
sempre quello di cercare di dare il
massimo per vincere
mi sono accorta invece che quegli
strumenti sono venuti sono venuti fuori
altre situazioni dell'acqua che pianeta
nel mondo del lavoro nello stagno gruppo
con persone che di sport non hanno
magari mai mai trattato nelle amicizie
nei sentimenti nell'educare di mia
figlia
e allora ho capito che la tenacia e
qualunque ambito tu lo usi non è mai una
virtù a fondo perduto